apprendre sur le terrain voilà
l'objectif de ces élèves sur ce chantier
nature à beaune l au delà d'un simple
exercice s'est mise en pratique
permettent aux étudiants de travailler
sur des situations concrètes comme ici
en entretenant un sentier de randonnée
l'objectif de cet aménagement est de
permettre de rendre ce sentier de
praticable par les randonneurs en leur
aménageant des passerelles qui leur
permettait de passer donc le but c'était
de d'installer des passerelles donc on a
creusé place et des rondins de bois
ensuite on a utilisé des sortes de des
plaquettes qui était donc déjà une
disposition en bois les apportez donc a
donc avec tes des grandes équipes on les
a donc disposé on a essayé de les
renforcer pour que du coup ça soit bien
enfoncés dans le sol et que ça tienne
bien fruit d'une collaboration entre le
parc régional de la vallée de chevreuse
et l'école tecomah à jouy en josas
ces événements sont bénéfiques à tous
donc le partenariat est intéressant
entre notre école et le parc naturel
naturel régional de la haute vallée de
chevreuse puisque nous avons la chance
grâce aux hautes nerfs de découvrir des
endroits et des sites naturels protégés
est classé et d'intervenir en respectant
nos commandes bien réel et qui permet
aux élèves d'être vraiment mises en
situation concrètes les élèves ça leur
permet d'apprendre un peu
de découvrir des milieux de découvrir
les techniques de découvrir les manières
de gérer ces milieux et nous ça nous
permet d'avoir à chaque fois entre 20 et
25 jeunes très motivés avec des
professeurs qui les encadre très bien
passé quelque chose de très enrichissant
car ça me permet donc justement nous
confronter à la réalité du terrain de
tester la théorie à la pratique donc sur
le lieu-même et de voir justement si
déjà ce genre de métier pour nous plaire
plus tard un partenariat s'effectue en
une fois par mois depuis trois ans qui
s'avère enrichissant pour les élèves
comme pour les communes